Kindle is with us in Fairfax Virginia
welcome to Dave Ramsey show Kendall hey
Dave how are you you too what's up so
I'm on baby step number three and I'm
been living with my family when I got
out of debt and now I've saved it up
about enough for six months I was living
in my current situation but I'm
wondering if I should save up you know
if I was kind of on my own had my own
apartment which would probably be about
double well yeah if you're gonna move
out which would be your plan right yes
then you would need an emergency fund of
that I'm not sure you have to have that
saved up before you move out so how much
money do you have saved
11,000 okay and what is your income 160
your incomes a hundred and sixty
thousand yes and you're at home well I
have to get out of debt first okay oh
you are you out are you out of debt yes
I got out in December and then I save
eleven thousand the past couple months
right and how much debt did you pay off
well I didn't have a job for a year so I
wrecked I dipped into my savings and
racked up about thirty thousand and paid
that off in six months what do you do I
do technology consulting good for you
how old are you 36 cool I would move out
immediately
you make $150,000 a year in consulting
and my project is actually ending this
week and then I go on the bench for a
month and if I don't find a position
then I then I lose my job okay so I
don't you know so then I get a severance
of about a month but I don't want to go
on the bench for how long a month
starting win this next Monday okay all
right so a month from now you're gonna
know what's going on exactly
okay if you've gotten a job a month from
now that's similar to what you have now
move out right okay if you haven't you
may need to stay until you land
something because you've gone from 160
to 0
correct yeah and that would be a problem
with $11,000 so yeah I'm okay I didn't
know the routing realize the income was
unstable so let's go ahead and pull up
as much pile up as much cash as we can
during this time while you're on the
bench are you paid yes paid for a month
and then I would go to seven for a month
okay so pile up all of that cash yes as
your urgency fund keep piling it but at
the point that you have a stabilized
your income meaning you landed a job
there or somewhere else move out
immediately okay not not in 24 hours but
I mean within a week or two go find you
a place to live you make good money
right and should I be saving for like
because I was looking at either getting
a car or a house and so I'm just
debating like alright so you're saying I
can move out you know if I stockpile all
of that yeah and then but I kind of want
to buy a house and if I rent and I'm
just like oh go rinse knowing that I'm
to be a grown-up go rent something you
make $160,000 a year
all right if you've stabilized that I
mean shut up go rent something for a
little while start piling up money for
for your down payment on the house don't
live with mom and say but you make
$160,000 a year don't you say this out
loud a bunch of times right it's time to
move and call me up making twelve
thousand bucks okay so it's time it's
time and no I would not go by right now
and you don't have a down payment and an
emergency fund and you need both before
you buy and be debt-free and it sounds
like you've got to move up in car or buy
your first car how much car do you have
now I am driving my sister's 2004 a car
from college it's not your car well it's
my family card and they just let me I've
been driving a career okay well so you
know probably one of the first things
you're gonna do save up and buy you
about ten thousand our car and give them
their car back yes right or maybe they
want to sell it to you yes I mean they
said they'd give it to me oh yeah okay
cool that'd be fine I just don't want
you to live off of them any more so I
want you to have your own car have your
own place have your own life I'm not
saying you have to not ever speak to
them again but it's time to time to move
on especially
when you stabilize this wonderful income
of yours congratulations